now let's get started by introducing my
esteemed colleagues let me briefly share
some background in each of the
presenters you will hear from today
first we have Pam Hines professor Hines
is an associate professor in the
management science and engineering and
co-director of the Center for work
technology and organization at Stanford
her research and teaching leveraged
their social sciences organizational
behavior in particular to understand the
effects of Technology on groups and
teams and organizations pamela is
probably most known for her research on
international distributed work teams and
she's increasingly interested in culture
she just embarked upon a study of how
design practices and Design Thinking
vary in different regions around the
world
Pamela believes that cultural context
shapes the practices that are possible
and appropriate in different settings
and that are honoring these differences
is key to innovation
she is the co-editor with Sarah Keesler
of the book distributed work next I'd
like to introduce Michael berry Michael
is a consulting assistant professor in
the mechanical engineering department at
Stanford University teaching need
finding and cross-cultural design also a
guest lecturer at the Harvard School of
Business and at the University of
California house School of Business
Michael teaches the nation's top
students how to connect innovation to
new understandings of customers a
founder of point Ford Michael has over
two decades of experience providing
strategic innovation about critical
early stages of the product development
process with a wide range of expertise
from engineering to design to cultural
studies
he has restructured research and
innovation processes provided strategic
project management and design over 80
products from mainframes to disposable
diapers now I'd like to turn it over to
Michael to get us started today thank
you very much for that introduction
let's move on to our first slide here we
are
culture and design thinking is kind of
the title today and we have kind of a
question why focus on culture why is
that going to be of importance to you
guys well
in our experience a lot of Western
companies see developing and emerging
markets as absolutely intoxicating just
a small fraction of these new consumers
just make head spin
so what in our experience often happens
um well the entrepreneurs and marketers
will visit say for example Beijing or
Shanghai for a week and they'll see
gorgeous modern cities they'll check
into a fancy hotel and run some focus
groups relative to whatever product
they've got get some answers and then
launch into all of China well as you
might guess things often don't work out
as they expect simply hoping that you're
going to get this huge group and that
your product designed here is going to
sitt often isn't what happens and we see
is China
like most emerging markets has very
complex cultures and they are
transitioning very fast rates we see
incredible change going on some of that
change is along known patterns other
times that change is is very very
different than what we've seen before
and providing any kind of product or
service to these millions we believe
requires different kind of knowledge so
we teach and Stanford is certainly known
for this thing called design thinking
and at the core of satisfying and being
having successful products as
understanding people's needs but their
different kinds of needs and how they're
expressed now those explicit needs that
people can talk about readily and then
they're the ones that we feel a very
important tied to innovation and that's
the implicit needs we have we refer to
as a cultural iceberg and with that
cultural iceberg a lot of the behaviors
and and responses to products and
services are pretty much above the
surface we can see them
we can record them we have us we can
gather kind of straightforward empirical
data and then other things below the
surface this is the assumptions and
values that people have a hard time
directly talking about and as you might
guess as you get into different cultures
these things vary dramatically and can
have huge impact on the kind of products
that we offer so just to summarize the
explicit needs other needs we can
readily observe and discuss now the fact
that you're staying in a four-star hotel
may not mean you're even seeing what's
really important and then of the
implicit needs and these are the things
that even people within the culture are
not necessarily aware of but we look at
ways to get at them um Pam offers a
really nice definition of culture and
she's going to talk a little later but
Pam describes culture as a fuzzy set of
attitudes beliefs behavioral norms the
basic assumptions and values that are
shared by a group of people we find in
many ways that culture is how people
solve problems and when they start to
think and frame problems differently we
may be seeing a different culture what's
important is that these shared
assumptions influence each member's
behavior and are shared between that
group we're seeing not just the nature
of the behavior but the meaning people
give their behavior this is what makes
up culture and at the end of the day
this is what we try to understand and
there's lots of anthropologists both
academic and applied who have been
working on this and I think this idea
that culture fundamentally constitutes
who we are what people do yes we have
sort of personal schemas and things that
drive what we do but yes I we have found
that the largest determiner
what makes us do what we do and think
the way we think is culture and this is
why we want to understand it people
share their thoughts with people around
them and what's critical is these
thoughts are both shared in public we
can get at them and when we start to
find cultural stories we find they're
shared across that culture as I said
it's kind of what we study I want to
give you though a kind of cautionary
note and it's that this is some work
that hazel Marcus has done Americans
have a really tough time understanding
this idea of difference and she's done a
lot of testing so for example she showed
a group of Japanese students Japanese
and Chinese college students patterns
and American students patterns and
what's interesting is the American
students consistently picked the set of
patterns on the Left Asian students the
patterns on the right and it was a sense
of both the pattern on the Left
represented something that was more
interesting a little more dynamic
reflective of what a good pattern is
pattern on the right suggested another
set of norms so for Americans we often
see that and believe that cultures
differ and essentially we see cultures
as Americans with people who speak
different languages we'd like to believe
well everybody's kind of different
individually we're still all the same
right it's at that idea of equality and
the only difference is language and what
we've seen is that the differences are
fundamentally can be very important so
on the one hand and looking at this
graph we're looking at sort of cultural
attributes versus ideas of normalcy to
bell curves and you can compare two
cultures Asia in the u.s. pretty much
things are the same but then they're on
the outsides of those curves
what we call kind of cultural slivers
these are the issues that are somewhat
different sometimes its meaning
sometimes its behavior depending on the
product or service you're building
sometimes it matters sometimes it
doesn't so let me give you an example to
some work again from hazel and it was
understanding Japanese baseball and here
are two sporting activities that between
our two countries are almost exactly the
same and what's interesting though is
when our ballplayers go to Japan they
assume the rules are the same outfits
the same what could be different and all
of a sudden a baseball player the teams
that he's on will be two three runs
ahead and he will hit a home run and as
he circles the bases the crowd is silent
everyone is kind of upset and disturbed
with what he's just done it homee be
expecting cheers what's going on and for
our players
it's discovering that in America it's
very much an individualistic job right
and success is what matters beating the
hell out of the other guy that's you
know showing how good you are that's
what's most important and in Japan
baseball is very much a collective way
of life it's symbolic of that it's more
than just kind of physical and mental
ability it's also speaks to a kind of
social and moral test and when you sort
of humiliate your opponent you've done a
disservice to the larger culture and
they said this is a subtle difference
and for our players they may never get
in that Japanese mindset but they can
begin to learn the rules and things that
will help them fit in and that's in
essence what we want to do for you guys
so I want to let Pam talk about some
strategies okay so I'm going to talk
about some of the different strategies
that have been used over the centuries
and decades for designing markets that
span one country's region or national
boundaries
these include translation localization
internationalization and more recently
adaptive and adaptable system so I'll go
into each of these in a little bit more
detail so translation has been used for
centuries as a means to enable trade
across language barriers even today
translation is widely used for goods
such as clothing and toys where the
identical product is going to be sold in
different language markets translation
includes more than just translating the
the words in the language and includes
spelling variants and British versus
American English punctuation writing
direction and so forth so it's
everything having to do with the
language and communication translation
can be and has been very effective for a
variety of products and services and
it's probably in fact a necessary
component of just about any strategy for
introducing a global product or service
but it tends not to be adequate in
today's global markets Facebook for
example has historically taken a largely
translation approach in Japan so for
example translating Facebook without
much in the way of any kind of
localization efforts
mixie in contrast is a social networking
site made by the Japanese for the
Japanese it looks very similar works
very similarly in a lot of ways but
newcomers can only join by invitation
which provides the degree of privacy and
safety that users feel they need in
Japan in order to divulge their
identities online communication on the
site is centered on the Nicci or diary a
concept that's deeply seated in the
Japanese psyche and this has resulted in
very different levels of adoption for
Facebook versus Nixie reports are varied
but one source indicates that mixi have
about 12 million
unique users in June 2007 and June 2008
whereas Facebook had about hundred and
seventy two thousand in June 2007 and
five hundred thirty-eight thousand in
June 2008 so during that same time
period indications are also that users
of mixi are more engaged than they are
in facebook so for example they spend
more time they contribute more and so
forth so it just is a more enriching
more fulfilling experience for the
Japanese to use the product that was
actually designed in a way that's really
resonant with their culture so in this
day and age
translation usually just is not an
adequate strategy users are increasingly
demanding more so the second strategy
that we'll talk about is localization
this has also been around a long time
localization is basically the process of
adapting and oftentimes this is used for
example with software the product or
service for specific region by adding
locale specific components so McDonald's
is one of my favorite examples they
really do remain largely the same across
cultures you know people can walk into
any McDonald's around the world and
recognize that they're in fact in a
McDonald's but they're also noted for
their outstanding efforts at
localization they have met cafes
throughout Europe extensive vegetarian
selections in India as well as the
Maharaja Mac that has two all lamb
patties the MEK falafel in Egypt that
served on a PITA
green tea and samurai pork burger in
Thailand and so on and so forth so just
wonderful localization efforts that
indicate a sense of what it is that's
needed in those environments and then on
top of that of course they've also
localized their advertising their
language and so forth so a pretty
complete strategy language localization
in
translation as well as a host of other
elements based on the local context
translation and localization have been
the bread and butter of multinationals
for decades but it's a relatively narrow
context having little to do with a real
deep understanding of the culture more
recent focus has really shifted to
internationalization so
internationalization strategies are
focused on making the product work
anywhere so the hope is that a product
can work across cultural barriers across
language barriers without really the
need for localization the motivation
here is to make just one product and be
able to get the economies of scale so
car manufacturers for exempt for example
General Motors has really made a push to
do that with cars the hope is to have
one line that can produce a line of cars
produce a particular vehicle that can
then be sold anywhere around the world
so for example with seat belts I'm
thinking about how to make seat belts
they basically design seat belts for the
toughest regulatory environment and then
assume that that seat belt configuration
will work anywhere in the world the
iPhone is another example it has very
little localization with the expectation
when it was introduced that there would
be 3G or 4G networks in their major
markets around the world and that the
cool factor of iPhone would sell around
the globe this assumption is that
products can be made that can really
skirt or cultural or language
differences and they often rely on the
value of the culture that was embedded
in the product so for example French
wine Nike running shoes and so forth in
some sense and buying these products
our international they're also
reflecting sort of buying into an
American culture of French culture a
Japanese culture wherever that product
was designed and kind of what it what it
symbolizes but mostly I would argue that
this is a myth even with the iPhone
there are significant issues with its
fit for example in China and part due to
cost Wi-Fi Wi-Fi connectivity is not as
pervasive across China lack of iTunes
availability and penetration and so
forth made it a fairly tough sell
particularly early on in China and then
finally I want to talk a little bit
about adaptive and adaptable systems
these are systems that are increasingly
being built to learn about users
behavior and the environment in which
they're operating and then the systems
themselves adjust accordingly so they're
really responding to the needs that are
expressed by users through their
behavior in interacting with these
systems so what's common across all of
these approaches and we've got a poll
for you here ok so what we're asking
here is what's common across all these
approaches one is you know they don't
lead to innovative products and services
the blue is they assume product
stability number 3 yellow they don't
change the underline metaphor of the
product the green is that they assume a
very developed world centric approach
and 5 the purple they all end in IO n ok
great so I'm going to go forward here
one of the assumptions actually all of
the answers were correct except the last
one because adaptive in the
just systems doesn't end in IOM but the
rest are correct well one of the
assumptions in all these strategies
including translation localization
internationalization and adaptation oh
they do all in denial and well there you
go
not only how you read it is that the
product is stable in other words there's
a foundation on which the skin of the
product is actually changed but those
changes tend to be largely cosmetic not
really changing the underlying metaphor
and that means the products may be
acceptable for use in another culture
but they don't necessarily fit well into
those cultures they don't really
resonate with the needs of the people in
those cultures hence the lack of success
of Facebook and other US products in
China that made service level changes
rather than really understanding deeply
the underlying needs in those markets
and of those people we just need to look
for example at the successes of Baidu as
a search engine in China and Alibaba
especially Taobao which is touted as the
eBay of China to see the effect of
having products that are truly sensitive
to these local needs I like to think of
it as it's like wearing a shoe that sort
of fits but it gives you blisters you
know it works it's something that you
can walk around in but if there's a shoe
available that doesn't give you blisters
you're immediately going to drop the
first pair and move to the other
according to a study that was done by
Deloitte a few years ago fewer than 50%
of companies competing in emerging
markets excuse me have achieved their
goals largely because the products are
unsuccessful with significant segments
of the market and that's really what
we're talking about here is how do you
get to those significant segments of the
market in those emerging those emerging
environments
of course a lot of products and services
are very successful this way and they
have done over many many years but the
global market is changing I think
there's less tolerance for shoes that
cause blisters and we believe that many
products and services can be much more
successful than they are today by
thinking more deeply about these
underlying needs so we advocate global
design which is thinking about all
products and services being located
somewhere located in some cultural
environment in some language context in
some geographic region and honoring the
culture and the context of that region
in thinking through what the underlying
metaphor will be for that product in the
course we'll talk in much more detail
about the framework that you see here it
advocates a process of understanding
needs through observation developing
frameworks creating imperatives and then
coming up with solutions that meet those
underlying needs by doing this we can
determine the real underlying needs of a
given culture or region and have some
hope of actually coming up with a
solution that's completely different and
ideally suited for a targeted region and
we believe that this is where the true
innovation and where Design Thinking
comes in so Michael is now going to talk
to you about a case study that
exemplifies the ideas that we've talked
about so far Thank You Pam and and by
the way this kind of reflects also our
sort of structure within the class I
think we are certainly interested in
theory but we really are concerned with
practice and both in having you engage
and through case studies so give you
just a little case study to kind of give
you a sense for how this works and it's
a case study about Wrigley and Wrigley
cells
different kinds of gum and confection
products around the world and we were
asked to understand breath and how they
could create breath products that would
better fit the needs of many many
different countries now they started out
with an international lies ation
approach they wanted to have a single
product a single set of brands single
packaging that would go everywhere and
that was kind of their starting point
kind of worked until they hit China and
sales in China and this is all late 90s
all in the start to 2000 had been pretty
flat in fact they had had one disaster
where a package which essentially was a
resealable packaged plastic package of
gum pellets which had done very well in
the US and the UK was introduced into
China and everyone saw it it was modern
and nice uh
it simply didn't move the Chinese found
it kind of awful much much too just the
dismay of Wrigley who this was a kind of
a top-selling product what's wrong isn't
fitting so um we looked at lots and lots
of countries around the world and talk
to people about breasts and one would
assume that's sort of a challenging
topic because um the idea was well and
this was again another assumption within
the company that well bad breath is
simply the absence of good breath so
it's really about particulates it's
about cleaning
it's very akin to brushing teeth and we
actually found that's not true
in the next slide here are some
relationships of how people think about
breath around the world and we're going
to start with the US and we've divided
people consistently talk about breath in
terms of removal as I said there's
particulates and malodor and they've got
to get rid of it and then
this thing called enhancement and that's
actually a little more complicated and
in the US we find as most people think
in terms of removal and very little
sense of enhancement now you have to
remember Wrigley is a US company based
in Chicago Wrigley Stadium and again
their view was well everyone must think
roughly the same way well as we went
through the world UK a little different
the overall sort of intensity of
feelings are different got a lot more
sense of enhancement and we'll all talk
to you a little more about what we mean
by the answer in Germany the enhancement
in fact is the most important aspect
people talk much more about good breath
their ability to link it to grooming how
they feel that's what's really at issue
last one China so two things one good
breath the enhancement side was more
important but overall the sense of this
idea of breath was kind of a mystery
there was simply well good breath which
is how your mouth should be all the time
and then the idea of bad breath is
something that existed only if you were
sick or really had a serious hygiene
problems and that people simply didn't
have bad breath it just wasn't something
that was out there
so we then and this sort of gives you a
glimpse this diagram shows all the
individual needs states within the
removal and enhancement side and we've
actually started to take apart and I'm
not going to go into detail here but we
took apart what those individual needs
states were for each country it turns
out China probably had the most complex
set of needs across all the need states
of any of the countries despite the fact
that the overall interest was pretty low
so Wrigley started out a sense that
maybe we needed to understand China
better maybe if we understood these
needs and we might be able to affect
behavior so we went into a six major
cities
and for outlying areas what are called
sort of second and third tier cities and
did lots and lots of both interviews
these were people who are willing to let
us hang out with them for our half a day
or so we gave them homework assignments
where we asked people to keep Diaries of
what they did we also did things like
displacement where actually had people
change what they did for a period of
time if they were gum chores we'd ask
them to use mints we'd ask them to keep
fresh breath not using gum or if they
weren't gum chewers before only do it
with gum and we started to collect data
from what we were seeing um so a number
of things came out first one and this
has to do with some basic features of
that plastic resealable bag that I
mentioned before well it turns out that
one of the reasons it failed was in
China sharing it's really really
important and there's also a sense that
I may be sharing in a location that is
like a department store incredibly clean
as modern as anything we've seen
or I could be sharing in an environment
where there is an open sewer and it's
kind of not so nice I have lots of
interesting smells so notions of Hygiene
and how you share are really important
and the idea that I put my hand into a
bag take apart I've contaminated the
whole bag and as Americans we don't have
that sensitivity in China very sensitive
there's also this notion of what's
referred to as controlled sharing in
America we will and and UK as well we
will hand over the pack of gum and say
help yourself in China there's a sense
that I want to maintain control and give
you the piece or pieces and at that
sense of where it's coming from is
always maintained so we started to look
at different kinds of physical packaging
that would support these things and it
was actually almost serendipitously that
we try
a vitamin bottle and in many ways a
vitamin bottle isn't as effective as
individually wrapped pieces but people
responded to it extremely well
they loved the plastic snap the plastic
snap two people said this guarantees
freshness even though the pellets
themselves the tabs weren't individually
wrapped we also noticed and this was as
we let people play with this particular
packaging they did something really
unique in fact we'd never seen it
anywhere in the world the teens figure
this out first that the lid the snap
plastic lid that had a living hinge you
could pop a single piece of gum into the
lid and hand it to someone kids went
nuts no you had to develop a little
skill in doing this but we discovered
that this packaging had both some
functional benefits but more importantly
had a lot of meaning that tied to
sharing that tied to freshness and also
had an interesting it was a new sort of
bit of language as I flipped a pellet
into the lid and handed it to you it was
a gesture that was both intimate and and
novel so we introduced this package
pretty early on and it started doing
really well well we also did some other
things we connected this package with
Doublemint which had been a kind of
old-fashioned brand in the US and
Doublemint in fact wasn't a breath brand
at all what's interesting is and in fact
here it was a problem that Chinese
absolutely refused to call a product
what Wrigley wanted them to call it in
China
Doublemint was referred to as
double-arrow they just wouldn't use the
right name darn them um but this idea of
double-arrow actually had a lot of
meaning to it
it spoke about change it spoke about
modernity in fact the Chinese talked in
especially the kids talked about
different double-arrow products some of
which Wrigley didn't even make yet so
we encouraged Wrigley to stop thinking
in terms of internationalization and you
already have this very powerful brand
that will link to this idea of breath
there's also another tricky thing with
breath and if you remember I talked
about in China unlike here breath either
meant something kind of normal or
something really really bad and you
can't share something that's taking care
of a really really bad problem if I'm
sharing a product and it says to you you
have bad breath I'm in a lot of trouble
so I needed to figure out how do I
communicate the importance of this
product the quality of the product but
without flagging that you have stinky
breath so part of it came from a family
of offerings that we started to look at
different flavors different modes so
that within the sharing we could tie it
to people's choices but more importantly
was a brand and the double arrow needed
to be linked to important piece of
meaning unique to China and I want to
show you an ad and I'll explain you it
was referred to as the the open door ad
and just to let you know in China as I
said we were looking for a symbol
something that didn't directly say this
deals with bad breath but something that
was a metaphor a symbol of it that
everybody would understand but nobody
would take offense hat so I want to
share with you an advertisement
gender Trump a column on the Chilcotin
Han series in Kochi in two months in
okay so where did we just see
well one this was an enormous ly
successful ad in China and and how come
well one it used the notion of sliding
door of a doorway to talk about breath
not as something stinky or malodor but
it's about being allowed in and doorways
are very important in China the other
thing that's very very important you'll
notice in the ad is this is about
businesspeople most ads about brass deal
with relationships and romance and what
we found is courtship relationships in
China are first and foremost start with
business romance comes later so the idea
that for lots of people
this well-groomed man wasn't being
allowed in yeah he could see through the
door but until he used the double arrow
and again the double arrow now
signifying opening doors and that we're
not directly talking about breath but we
are talking about grooming you also have
to remember this is a world where social
lubrication is about cigarettes so we're
competing directly with cigarettes which
are also seeing among a lot of our
interviews families teens were starting
to question this becomes an alternative
to the cigarette as that door opener so
the good news we figured out how to talk
about Brad breath without talking about
it we linked double mint which had been
just a brand about confection we now
emphasize the part of the brand that in
China was truly meaningful that
everybody was all
already pointing us to which was the
double arrow and linked it to that
opening door and lastly we tied it to a
new plastic container a plastic
container that spoke of modernity its
spoke of freshness in a very different
way and it spoke about sharing all the
components that again tie to
professional courtship relations so the
good news is after the years of
stagnation I talked about in 2006 sales
in China increase to 13% excuse me they
increase 13% over what they had been
what that turns into is China now sells
more dumb than all the other countries
in the world come on
so suddenly the executive team in China
who had sort of been kind of asking for
help being given sort of the dribs and
drabs of wriggly have now suddenly kind
of taken over and are leading the charge
in terms of innovation of what's
possible and how to think about gum so
with that that is our case study for
today and introduction to to
cross-cultural design we would love to
take any questions or comments
great thanks Tim Michael so I'd like to
remind folks please submit your
questions and I'm going to describe a
little bit about how you can learn more
about today's topics and as soon as I
finished we're going to have them answer
questions from the audience so I'd like
to talk about a little bit about our
Stanford advanced project management
program here at Stanford we're pleased
to offer the Stanford advanced project
program for the past 11 years with IP
solutions and in partnership with
Professor Ray Leavitt we believe that
the s APM certificate is a unique
offering because it blends the industry
and practical experience from experts at
IPs with the Stanford theory and
research this resulting in a truly
rigorous and advanced program also what
we tried to do in creating this program
is offer this course and some flexible
delivery options so participants
either come to Stanford's campus in
March June and/or September also watch
the courses online via streaming video
anytime and also through your company
work site through IP solutions they can
create tailored workshops for cohorts of
20 or more and as you see here for the
Stanford advanced project management
certificate program it was created for
leaders and managers who want to improve
their ability to convert strategy into
action through project program and
portfolio management and that of their
organizations and teams so we take an
organizational perspective in the
curriculum that focuses on operating in
a global context and improving
productivity and possibility and here
you can see laid out on the slide that
there are three required courses
converting strategy into action
mastering the project portfolio and
leadership for strategic execution and
the program requires participants to
complete a total of six courses so we've
included a number of electives that you
can take including this new course that
we will be offering in June innovating
global products and services sort of
what our webinar was based off today the
calendar here shows the dates in March
in June for our on-campus events with
the core and elective sort of details as
well as some pricing details for June we
have early registration date of May 1st
whereas if you sign up by May 1st you
can save about $250 per course and as
you can see that our innovating global
products and services will be running
from June 13th through 15th this year
with that we would just like to take a
moment to conduct a poll that we would
appreciate your feedback on if you could
just take a moment to indicate your
level of interest in the essay p.m.
certificate program that would be great
we also are very excited that we often
get current enrollees as well as alumni
to the program who attend these webinars
on a regular basis so just letting you
know this way we can have folks if
you're interested in coming in March in
June who can help support any questions
that you may have or if you're
interested in bringing the SI p.m.
program to your company site as well
also if you have any questions about how
our online courses work
great thank you so much please make sure
that we have some questions from the
audience today that we can ask great
okay so here's a question the product
design did not change however it's a
message to introduce it changed the dome
was still dumb I agree that the crafting
of the message was important but the
design didn't change is there any
response to that no and here's a one way
of thinking about design um there's
certainly the functions of usability
which to your point about gum hadn't
changed dramatic and the use shifted a
little bit the physical didn't change
but the meaning that the gum had for
people did change now again that was
supported both in terms of branding and
advertising but it also was linked with
a physical link to the package so you're
right while the gum didn't change how it
was perceived especially through the
packaging and again it was only recently
that Wrigley was beginning to be aware
that packaging determined a lot of sales
as opposed to just being the flavor and
consistency of the gum so absolutely
right but we would say the design
changed a lot okay okay we have another
question when you talk about culture
aren't there variations and culture
based on age groups my experience is
that younger generations culture is
often an adaptation of their home
country and many popular cultural
aspects how do you design products to
consider these differences that's a
great question and that's absolutely
right they're different age groups there
are different regions one of the things
that we'll talk a lot about in the class
is the challenge where typically when
we've looked at culture when we thought
about products and services for
different countries we've thought about
a country as a single unit where
everybody has the same cultural
behaviors and cultural values and if you
just push that a little bit it begins to
fall apart I mean it's
in the United States it's true in parts
of Europe it's certainly true in China
that it that you don't have the same
culture across all demographic groups
across all regions and you are
approached to cross-cultural design is
to really go in and understand these
different groups in these different
regions and that's going to be true you
know in any kind of product design that
you do you know you're going to have
target market markets where there are
different different needs different
behaviors within different cultural
groups but I think it's especially true
when you're talking about large diverse
cultures again for example China and
China we also see dramatic differences
generationally because of the pace of
change in China historically people have
seen China as for example a very
collectivist kind of culture but one of
the recent policies has really shifted
that in in very important ways
so the one-child policy in China has
resulted in now kind of college-age kids
having grown up as a single child with
the the focus of their parents and their
grandparents no brothers and sisters no
cousins and that actually caused a shift
in the culture toward a more
individualistic perspective more like
what you would see in the u.s. so it's
very important to attend to these
generational shifts regional shift urban
versus rural because as the the person
asking the question mentioned exposure
to global media makes a difference so
all of this needs to be taken into
account
great okay our next question
how can you sell a product or service to
a country that has little need for such
an item or is really counterproductive
for the global future well-being so I
think they were referring to that in the
webinar that we covered that it appeared
to make products with better sustainable
qualities but the discussion suggested
the opposite so how can we sell a
product or service in a country that has
a little need for such an item okay well
I think that the you know very much the
position that we're taking is that you
don't that you really don't want to sell
a product or service into a country
where there's not a need for it and in
fact we would argue that that's actually
probably not the most productive
strategy that in fact what you want to
do is really understand these underlying
needs these the deep needs that people
have and try to then deliver products
that meet those fundamental needs in the
in the Wrigley example and you are right
were we heightening an anxiety that
didn't exist before and in one sense we
were making people more aware of breath
in a way that they had in fact the
notions of what good breath were created
as these products were introduced into
the market I think there's the other
side and this has to do with cigarette
smoking and rates of cancer and we were
looking at Wrigley gum as an alternative
to essentially what is a scourge a
health scourge within China and it's the
sense of providing an alternative social
lubricant to something that is just a
disaster great as a part of a product
design project is it important among
many things to sell the idea internally
that considering the cultural nuances
will outweigh the cost incurred in
designing for globalization what are the
tools in your arsenal that you have
successfully used a
Dress these concerns in large
corporations and also a second part of
the question is are they different in
the high-tech world okay so I I
understand the question to be you know
it how do you convince your organization
or your management that investing in
maybe a more expensive and
labor-intensive process of understanding
the global needs is actually going to
pay up pay off in the long run I think
one of the ways that I've seen be very
effective in organizations is through
case studies actually sharing with
organizations some of the ways that you
know as Michael's example of wriggly how
it actually transformed their ability to
participate in the market and I think
that numerous examples are out there of
ways that organizations have done this
and also ways that organizations have
failed miserably and very expensively
when they haven't done that and I think
that those provide very compelling
stories for management there there is
another approach here and it has to do
with Pam's diagram where she shows the
foundational differences and we're
actually involved right now with a very
large provider of operating systems and
search engines and they are very
concerned about the idea that we should
look at difference because in their
minds if we look at difference we're
going to have to change our product and
changing our product is kind of
unthinkable especially with the idea
that we kind of have an evolutionary
model that our product is at the top of
the evolutionary scale and everybody
else is trying to basically get to where
we are one we've seen that very often if
this is by the way very high-tech
the meaning around the internet
around search is dramatically different
in different parts of the world
especially Asia and Southeast Asia and
that products that are about technology
and the idea that we don't want to be
left behind is the American view we need
to keep up we need to stay with
technology and there's a currency in
being high-tech we've seen in Southeast
Asia that's not necessarily the case
that the idea of the technology alone
doesn't have a lot of value it does have
value as being left out that's very
different than being left behind and
that social component of high-tech is
what in fact is most important and how
do you leverage that so back to the
foundation the anxiety is that the
Foundation's wrong we have to start over
as opposed to and this is sort of the
statement of the baseball there are
enough similarities that what we need to
help with are seeing the the landmines
the roadblocks and that it's important
to be inclusive but in so much is like
the baseball players you can find the
rules that will allow you to be
successful without necessarily having to
start over and that's we found a very
good useful a very very positive way of
selling this idea of cultural difference
into companies where they're not really
sure cultural differences going to
matter great so that's going to conclude
our question-and-answer portion for
today I definitely like to thank Michael
and Pam for their taking their time out
today and giving us a wonderful look
into different ways that culture affects
your product design and I look forward
to actually learning more in June when
the course comes to campus great so this
concludes today's webinar on global
product design and as a reminder you can
may now print a PDF of the slides by
selecting the print to PDF option in the
lower navigation bar also remember to
look for an email that will alert you
when the
and our becomes available to watch a
video format and also any further
information again thank you for joining
us today and I see that there are still
a couple questions in the queue and we
will stay after and answer those via
text through Live Meeting and make sure
that they're all answered and for the
rest of us those who have had their
questions answer you may now disconnect
thank you